hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
a square with a side length of 5 is
positioned with its corner in the center
of a square with a side length of 4 as
shown in the diagram
one side of the overlapping region
between the two squares is equal to 3.
the puzzle is to calculate the area of
the overlap between the two squares
that is to calculate the area of the red
shape
i thank ohad from israel for suggesting
this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so how can we figure this problem out
well the first thing is the side of
three is actually irrelevant to this
problem
we'll remove it
next we'll draw blue lines to extend the
sides of the square as shown
what does this do
notice the square with a side length of
four is now divided into four identical
shapes
each with an area equal to the red shape
therefore
each shape is equal to one-fourth of the
square's area
so the red region has an area equal to
the area of the square which is four
times four or four squared and then we
divide it by four
this will be equal to four
amazing
in fact we can extend this problem that
the area of overlap between the two
squares always has an area of four
so we consider a square with a side
length of four
and then we have a square with a side
length of five
what we'll do is we'll create a tiling
where we have four different squares
with a side length of five
notice the square with a side of four
is divided into four identical shapes
right now each with an area equal to
four
now this will be true even as we rotate
the squares with a side length of five
we still have the square with the side
length of four being divided into four
identical shapes each with an area equal
to four
now we can continue the symmetry as we
rotate the larger squares
the square with a side length of four is
always divided into four different
identical shapes
therefore each will have an area that's
one-fourth the area of the square
it's a pretty neat problem
and rotational symmetry solves this like
magic
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can math the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
news videos watch and share all of mind
your decisions videos email me a puzzle
presh
mindyourdecisions.com
read my books which are linked in the
video description and if you so choose
you can support me on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support